what's up guys and be showing you one of
the best ways to get magic experience
and make profit in the game super easy
few requirements stay tuned so we're
going to be making Brock teleport tabs
all you need is some coins some llamas
some soft clay teleport to your house
and highly recommended is the smoke
battle staff so you don't have to use
fire and arrows they're just built in
already and the only requirement for
this is 40 construction so you can build
a study room okay so we're going to
start out we're going to teleport to our
house you also need to hire a butler
so we can get your stuff out of the bank
for you so we're gonna go ahead and tell
them get 20 soft clay very good serves
as now we're going to run over to our
study go ahead and click it
and then we're going to click create all
and we're going to do this and I will
time it for an hour
and I will show you guys how long it
takes and I will show you how much XP I
get so in case you guys aren't sure how
to use the butler when you're almost
done with a load you click him he'll
give you the 20 click it again will say
very good sir go go and get the 20 and
while I was getting the 20 we're going
to go ahead and make some more tabs and
then he'll come back and when you're
almost out repeat the process and just
keep doing it so I actually
miscalculated how many rooms I need for
how long would it be here so I had to
quickly just leave the teleport stop the
time trader for my other account get a
ring of do a ring of wealth actually and
then teleport to the grant exchange and
then buy some more so just so you guys
know I didn't cheat or anything that's
how I got the more rooms and more clay
all right
thanks alright so I'm done so I'm gonna
go ahead and teleport to the grand
exchange I'm gonna keep the time running
set 55 minutes and to sell these is
probably and take about five minutes so
we're going to go ahead and let the time
keep going so if I sell them right we
can make like 500 40k we're going to go
ahead and actually let's just instance
home alright so much so I'm sold
I'll wait and I'll show you guys how
long it takes to sell mo alright so
they're all sold took about five minutes
to sell them all
so let's go ahead and do the math so 500
eight one seven zero K minus 7,000 of
the extra rooms about - the 6000
basically of the extra clay ABAT - the
price of all the law rooms I bought -
the price of all the clay that I bought
so 210 okay so okay so we can make 210 K
an hour getting this method that's great
and you can also get about 36 km/h
experience alright guys thanks for
watching and stay tuned for next video
[Music]